Brian a former police officer nearly got
away with murder but tonight Arthur
Sewell learned his fate and it's a story
the eight news now investigators have
been following Vanessa Murphy has the
update
former police officer Arthur Sewell
sentenced six to 15 years in prison for
killing Nadia Iverson in 1997. I don't
think there's enough Justice
um there won't be enough time uh surge
that would take and bring her back to us
Marie Coker is Iverson's sister she and
her mother and Iverson's best friend
wears shirts and bracelets in memory of
Iverson as they attended Sewell
sentencing Tuesday I've been praying and
hoping that he would do best every day
every day I prayed to God that
confession came more than 20 years after
the murder old rape kits were tested
police say Sewell was a match and
detectives questioned him in 2018. went
out for the with the intention of sexual
gratification
and when 367 went off it freaked me out
and I both did not panic Iverson's body
was found in this downtown Las Vegas
home under construction police said she
had a gunshot wound and an investigation
revealed she may have been sexually
assaulted the murder happened months
after Sewell resigned from Metro he was
convicted for abusing his power as an
officer after he was caught on video
forcing women to perform sexual acts
our tool and now there's
no joke
but this our tool
left his DNA
there but the confession Iverson's
mother had hoped and waited for would
later be tossed out a judge ruled the
detectives violated sewell's Miranda
rights by questioning him without an
attorney in November he pleaded guilty
to voluntary manslaughter with use of a
deadly weapon he could be released in
less than two years because of time he
already served in jail Iverson's loved
ones say they plan on attending his
parole hearings to make sure he stays
Behind Bars to serve the full term 15
years is not enough for anybody's life
and
I wish he would have gotten more
but I'm going to make sure that he is
staying in prison Vanessa Murphy 8 News
Now
the eight news now investigators reached
out to Sewell for an on-camera interview
a Metro spokesperson says he has
declined all media requests